varias generaciones han acudido a la
taberna de hybrid un pub independiente
en easlington detrás de la barra se
esconde una pequeña oficina en la que
Fátima la gerente prepara la nómina
desde el brexit le ha costado encontrar
a personal por un salario razonable su
otra gran preocupación el aumento de los
precios de la energía
el costo de la energía no solo afecta al
funcionamiento del negocio sino también
al costo de la comida y la bebida
estos vecinos han pasado la mayor parte
de su vida en esta zona siendo testigos
de la gentrificación
esto solía ser un pop increíble los
baños estaban arriba había otra barra
arriba mesas de billar
para poder charlar con la gente pero las
personas ya no hablan con los demás todo
se hace por teléfono
el pub es una institución pero hoy en
día el bajo poder adquisitivo implica
recortes
antes se tomaban distintas y ahora se
toman una buena o eligen un día
importante para salir antes la semana
tranquila era la última semana del mes
ahora empieza a partir del 15 se ve más
gente local o clientes que te dicen o no
tengo más dinero para el resto del mes
Fátima intenta negociar los precios con
los proveedores pero no tiene el poder
de las grandes cadenas de bares Allison
lanzó City stark un proyecto para ayudar
a los pads independientes de Londres
los grupos cuentan con equipos de
marketing y recursos para desarrollar
sus actividades lo que no es el caso de
los pops independientes que se centran
en contratar personal y atender a sus
clientes así pues hemos lanzado esta
iniciativa para atraer a los
consumidores a bares independientes a
los que no tendrían que ir
necesariamente
en 2020 y 2021 fue un año duro para los
pequeños negocios en los pubs con más de
un 10% de inflación anual la subida de
precios de la comida y de las facturas
básicas a veces están por encima del
200% los poops como este han tenido que
cerrar y otros podrían seguirlo pronto
con el fin de las ayudas del gobierno en
abril que regulan los precios del gas y
la electricidad